I am Iron Man the perfect ending for
Tony Stark and the perfect Marvel movie
but what if that was not one of Tony's
final moments before he snapped an
Avengers end game what if he never said
I am Iron Man well as it turns out there
was an alternate version of Tony Stark's
final moment where he did not say I am
Iron Man
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
an Avengers in-game editor has revealed
that there was an alternate version of
Tony Stark's final moment for avengers
endgame and this final moment according
to the editor was said to be completely
emotional raw and insane so let's talk
about these alternate versions of Tony
Stark's final moments and Avengers
endgame quick reminder I'm giving away
an Xbox one and a ps4 all you have to do
to enter for your chance to win to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and leave a comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain Jeff Ford
you may not have heard of his name but
he is an editing partner of the Russo
brothers that came with them to edit
Avengers endgame he's the legend that
came up with Tony Stark's final words I
am Iron Man
and in a recent interview with Collider
he has revealed that there were many
different alternate versions of Tony
Stark's final moment in this interviewed
he told Collider when we were putting
together the end of the movie when we
shot Tony's last moment in the first
round we shot a bunch of different
options
Robert had different ideas we give him
space to do that Joe and Anthony are
great about improv we shot a run of
different performances for the last
moment some of them were crazy some of
them we would have never used he goes on
to say that some of them were jokes some
of them were obscenities some of them
were completely emotional raw insane
things that he was doing and then some
of them were combinations of all three
of those things and as they went on to
try and find something that would work
they went on to find out that it wasn't
necessarily a final line that they
needed but more of a final moment
between Tony and Fanus a moment that
wasn't some kind of transaction but
literally this is how I want it to be
and this is how it is where Thanos would
say this is how I want it to be right
before he would attempt to snap but not
have the Infinity stones and then Iron
Man with the stones say this is how it
is and then snap Ford goes on to say
that would give the audience that moment
the exchange where Thanos says I am
inevitable and Tony says I am Iron Man
that couplet is what makes that work
when we found that OSes line
and led us to Tony's line we found
Dennis's line as part of a structure in
the script he says that line three times
in the movie at the beginning before his
head is chopped off in the middle he
hears himself say it again and then at
the end that symmetry is also why it's
interesting that was a discovery while
we were editing however according to
Ford the original ending that was
established for a very long time was
originally Tony Stark not saying
anything at all just him snapping Ford
says in that version Thanos didn't say
anything either
he had the gauntlet he looked at him
like I got you snapped looked couldn't
believe it turn to Tony tony raised his
hand and snapped it was beautiful it
worked really really well but what we
found was that Thanos needed an arc and
Avengers endgame that arc was his sense
of inevitability the story we'd been
telling was that Thanos as pitch in the
movie is no matter how many times you
try and stop me
you can travel in time you can do all
these things you're never going to win
it's a sense of destiny of I will always
be the one who wins they're trying to
undo destiny they're going against what
happened for the movie to have a
thematic coherence at the end of the
movie needed to be Thanos saying I told
you you cannot win and for Tony to say
but we can so the original final moments
for Tony Stark were originally just
going to be him snapping him just
looking at fan oohs Thanos looking at
Tony in a way that says I told you you
cannot win and then Tony looking right
back at him with a look that says but we
can this but we can eventually turned
out to be I am Iron Man
which I think everybody is really really
happy with even though I'm sure fans
would have been completely satisfied
just by seeing Tony Stark's snap I think
ultimately we are all more satisfied
with hearing him say I am Iron Man for
the very last time but let me know what
you think about this alternate version
of Tony Stark's final moments and let me
know what you think about the true
meaning behind I am Iron Man let me know
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
your chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff